Http is the core technology that
handles how data is exchanged over
the World Wide Web, so
let's discuss that for a bit.
Http stands for hypertext transfer
protocol and hails from the earlier days
of the web when computers transmitted
just basic webpage information.
So what is a protocol?
Well, a protocol is simply a predefined
set of rules that allows computers to
communicate and coordinate with one
another in order to complete a task.
In this case,
that goal is to exchange messages and
or data across the internet.
Well, how does this communication work?
Client computers, talking HTTP,
transmit messages containing
specific HTTP methods, or verbs,
that convey their intention or request
to a receiving computer or server.
The server receives and
interprets the message, reacts, and
then sends a response back through
the internet to the client.
This is a request and
response exchange paradigm.
Here are some examples of the most
commonly used HTP methods or
verbs used today.
Here's a GET.
Get means I'd like to get or
retrieve some data from you.
Server will respond with okay,
here's your information.
A post means I'd like to
create some new information.
A put means I'd like to update
some existing information.
Now, the server doesn't always
have to respond with a thumbs up.
Maybe something went wrong.
Maybe it doesn't know what
you're talking about.
And it could yield some sort
of unsatisfactory response.
Delete, just simply means that I'd like
to delete some existing information on
the server.
This was a quick overview of
the most commonly used HTP verbs but
you can find the complete
set linked below.
Typical web browsing tasks
like loading Facebook or
Google.com can consist of
hundreds of http requests.
What I'm want to do now is use
Chrome developer tools to show you
exactly what's getting loaded into
Google.com when we reload the page.
Developer tools has a number of useful
pieces of information and in this
case we going to click on the network
tab and I'm going to reload Google.com.
And we can see all
the little things that come
loading into the page right here.
See, some of them are documents,
some are images, some are scripts.
In the same way, EPI exchanges
contain multiple requests, but
are often an order of magnitude
smaller than loading a web page
mainly because there's so
much less data and media to load.